Every now and then the sun explodes
Without, warning blazing hot plasma spews into the solar, system with the force of about 20 million nuclear bombs
Depending on the direction of the explosion that plasma can, head straight for earth
These eruptions are called coronal, mass ejections or cmes and they happen when the sun's surface gets a little twisted
The sun is basically a giant ball of gas that's constantly dancing
When the sun gets a little too excited it twists its magnetic field too far which causes it to kink
Remember, when phones at cords and they get all tangled when you walk, and talk it's kind of like that
Eventually the tension builds and the kink snaps and the plasma explodes into a terrifying cloud of protons and electrons
Solar wind then takes the cloud of piping hot particles on a ride through the solar system
The plasma can travel at speeds up to seven million, miles per hour and if the cme
Is aimed at earth it could take as little as 12 hours to slam into our planets
lakes
Last time this happened, was in 1859 and the impact triggered a geomagnetic storm in our magnetosphere and
If that were to happen, today the storm could frier power grid
Leaving us all in the dark, so the next time the sun decides to explode
Let's just hope it's not aimed at us
You can catch new, episodes of spacecrafts every wednesday and you can watch a, more seeker here and learn about
Nasa's plan to launch a, solar probe that will travel
Closer to the sun than any spacecraft before it thanks for watching, make sure to subscribe